[Music]
hey
oh all right let's get back into it i'm
in
lag city this morning it has been
cutting on and off so
good time to be streaming but you know
oh i got the best stat ever see told you
[Music]
how's everyone doing excellent
let's go
god i hate the controls they're so like
there's like a delay when you move it
okay moving it moving it moving it
it's like
like he's really drunk or something oh
100 lay
very good or was we
all right big bubba lady that's right
uh let me re-accustom myself
to how you [ __ ] play this game doing
good so far
we have died zero times i felt like we
came from here
oh god
yeah we did no we didn't yeah we did
we did not jerrycon
uh i didn't know this was out on pc i
made a huge mistake getting this on the
playstation
i thought it was an exclusive oh
someone's calling me
[Music]
i hate playing this on controller
honestly oh big bubba no
we were lying to you
how did she not [ __ ] see us we were
right there like this
holy [ __ ]
miranda he's got two kids to inform you
that ethan winters has
escaped that fool heisenberg
because he is in my castle and has
already proven too much for my daughters
to handle
when i find him
no mother miranda yes
of course i understand the importance of
the ceremony
i won't let you down
that man will pay for what he's done
i don't get it what i do
all right continuing oh base
slice it i like how this started as
can you break the vases into you have to
break all the vases
all right she left mama mommy
hello
uh we were all called by mother miranda
to decide the fate of the child's father
there's thinking of that family meeting
it makes me shudder
do you think i am treated like a sister
to those miscreants
especially heisenberg that riffraff
wouldn't know proper manners if they
slapped him in the face
i should have sliced him to ribbons if
mother hadn't stopped me
why why does she treat me the same step
she gave me this castle obedient
daughters everlasting life
did she not am i not her favorite am i
not special have she seen my cakes in
the oven
i need a drink hello
don't be sad mama rose where are you
can we dip the baby in this
goddamn how do they make them this
though explain this can i wear it
turn bottom no
then what's the point all right i'm
gonna have to kill it now
oh
i keep locking doors in this game i
don't get it
i hate how that fat can i throw away the
family photo it's so irritating
that it shows up
oh here we go
we got a key guys we did it we solved
the puzzle it was difficult
but i managed to pull through
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it's mommy
all this for a child who isn't even here
what the hell dude do it do it to me
grateful
selfish whatever you want to do mom my
you lay your filthy manhands on
my daughters and now you even try to
steal
my property keep hitting me baby
oh no
rest while you can because i
will hunt you and i will break you
i like the sound of that break me please
do your worst absolutely
hallelujah we should probably do some
crafting right
let's see here uh-huh
we'll make one of those
we have so much ammo
[Music]
harder mommy
press me through the floor harder please
okay jump scare potential
no we were spared
okie dokie
i'm so rusty it always takes me so long
to get into console games
i like this place am i supposed to be
running or something
let's check this out
no
let's do the edges first ah yes
definitely meant to do that yeah oh
that's a lot of gold hello
mommy will be pleased
i'm a lucky guy another level
lever
oh ethan's hands are so [ __ ] up
again mom come on ribbons
please before you ever see
dude someone needs to make a compilation
of every time ethan's hands get [ __ ]
up
my hand is unusable mom can help it's
okay
[Music]
oh she's going that way well that's a
queen oh [ __ ]
ah can you all right you need
i can't even heal too late
all right she's going this way mommy no
no
no more i need my hand back i'm just
going to get my hand back there we go
there we go that's new
i still can't hit the lever
[Music]
where is she hello mama
she's committing ah
i wasn't honestly
mom i'm having a rough time
can i re-attack can we'll just pour some
disinfectant on it
honestly it should be fine
yay ah puzzle time excellent
oh we got the mask of sorrow
running will get you nowhere
i'm not running the game is forcing me
to do it it'll grow back
there we go it's fine there we go it's
fine
yeah just a little bit of tape there you
go
good as new honestly better now i like
it better now thanks mom
ethan is made of [ __ ] oh it's fine
yeah yeah yeah good good
good screw this castle good we got our
hand back
oh no are they attacking me i
i can't shoot it right now or can i oh i
can
hold up hold up guys
hold up i said hold up
thank you thank you
all right hold up i hear one on my right
anyway
[ __ ]
that's fine oh god the controls are so
irritating i swear to god
[Applause]
nailed it
is there more
there is more nice
just gotta take your time with the shots
there you go
[ __ ] nice
am i supposed to just escape this i mean
i'm getting money
all right let's try and escape all right
we did it no need to close the door
mommy i'm back
i forgive you we forgive her right
yeah we're cool
savory it's all tidied up i won't last
until dinner
oh it's her okay
[Laughter]
we'll go outside again that's fine
[ __ ] we should have killed all of these
god why are there so many
bro there's too many of you honestly i
don't have that much ammo
[Music]
guys i really i'm really low on my emma
i'm gonna have to knife some of you
[Applause]
[Music]
oh she attacks with their claws as well
oh maybe a dynamite would have been good
there we go
all right are we done here
i thought she would uh run out with me
so i can shoot her but that
clearly did not happen at all but we
cleared out the area so
who really won that one huh now
what are they doing scratching his back
that's nice of them
i don't really have a problem with this
place
at all seems like a
tourist location on the romanian
cover some board okay
so uh seriously where are we going we're
going and we're supposed to leave
uh-huh yeah courtyard yes oh merchant
room
save point labyrinth puzzle god that
controls i swear
there we go all of four uh-huh
yes
got plenty of ammo why
plenty full um
i have a feeling we're not supposed to
be here i'm walking backwards
i can't upgrade right now but we did get
a lot of money so hopefully we can
upgrade next time we see that
our man
i should have known that was like
this looks like a point of interest
ah yes this is where we're supposed to
go
hello hey hey
mommy song
all right we updated our map
cool we got the opera hall awaiting
that's cool
yes
oh please be aware the mistress lipstick
is missing
if anyone finds it could you they please
return it to her bathroom
it is custom made and therefore very
expensive
grand chambermaid
i also conveniently leave some was that
shotgun
no oh scary music
what a [ __ ] key
hello mommy what is that like
what a glitch
all right let's make as little noise as
possible
so they don't find us
one day since treatment the three girls
have stopped moving they
seem almost dead an insect flew out of
the elder's mouth and it appears to be a
common fly
in athens two days since treatment all
three bodies are covered in flies
it appears the flies are consuming their
flesh it happens
when i open a window some of the flies
drop dead to the floor it
would seem the cold petrifies them i
quickly close the window to
avoid weakening the insects further so
we are supposed to
destroy the windows four days since
treatment all three bodies have almost
been completely consumed by the insects
all that is life is
a dark rhythm human shaped mass of
creatures
it is this afternoon and the insects
have started to change color these those
are
around the face turned pale and those
around the lips turned out
deep crimson six days since treatment
the mass of
insects have transformed into human
bodies again all three girls awoke
looking at me like newborns i sense a
bond between us like mothers and
daughters
i have already decided the names bella
daniela and cassandra nice
oh that's nice whoa
that's kind of cool
well it's too bad we got to kill them
i'm their only
i'm the only sibling
oh [ __ ] all right let's get a sneaky
head shot
there it comes you ready run in the neck
oh [ __ ] sorry bud hey don't hunch over
when i'm about to shoot you
you got to be dead now why can't they
use their swords
oh i got lousy as a knife dude
the other one sounds like it's down
there
yeah it's down there somewhere i will
find you
but where
hello
hey you are i knew you were hiding
you make too much noise to be scary
bro i got i got so much room here
i got so much wiggle room you have no
idea
i got more wiggle room than you wiggle
baby
oh nice that's worth a lot of money
cheers mike
see if there was a scare now i'd be more
freaked out because that would be
more unexpected oh hello flower swords
ball i was looking for that
thank you
i feel like i could pick up any of these
items let me go
maiden of angel thingy
great what do i do with it
i don't know
oh we didn't did we check this no
oh do we have a lockpick we do
what do we get what do we get something
good oh
what we don't even have a sniper rifle
yeah what the [ __ ]
did we miss
hello where's the sniper rifle
where is it hiding a sniper rifle
or is it night way
oh i love these
oh yes
all right i think i'm gonna try and save
the shotgun ammos for the bosses
or the really tight situation vintage
piano let's
excuse me there's a song i need to play
i'm gonna need some
music bros helping me oh
[Music]
wait
there it is
[Music]
thank you
uh-huh
nailed it
his poor hands has to go through so much
excellent we have the key oh
more fly snap okay
scientific name none size five to six
centimeters excuse me what are they
describing here exactly
similar body structure to blow flies
although there are differences in the
head
in the head you say okay they are
carnivorous
and vigorously consume meat in order to
catch
unsuspecting prey they gather using
pheromones to mimic human
they are produced when a caddo lays eggs
in this hose but the flies themselves
are unaware
unable to produce reproduce they are
weak to sudden drops in temperature
okay got it okay i got it especially if
the temperature drops below 10 degrees
celsius or 50 degrees fahrenheit
their metabolism lowers and they go into
a dormant
cryo cryptobiotic state get the [ __ ] out
of here americans from the fahrenheit
we're in romania [ __ ]
similar to the cryptobiosis of
tardigrade
or polypedillum van der planky
van der planky out here in romania
my mind i must say
you can never find a good vendor planky
this days
ah here's the vein no that was restless
ah here's the bander
as they're crafting we can make some
nothing
i can make more if i get the van der
planky
check this out that looks important
are we perhaps back to somewhere we've
already been yes
we are okay
we're back here where am i supposed to
go
then i've been to the vineyard right
the library possibly been there
uh-huh
honestly kind of spaced out and i'm not
entirely sure where we need to go let's
try here again
so she loves the cold
can we take out the fire that become
cool
no they're there for aesthetic effect
i know there's a save station nearby
here yeah there so we make a right
okay let's try that
oh we missed this vas my apologies
definitely meant to hit r1 instead of r2
we missed it
like a weird i'm sorry what
oh i see we go here
it's a pleasure to see you safe how were
things
uh i'm
so sorry it turned out that way well
you'll find your way to her once you're
out of this castle
do you have need of anything for the
road ahead
yes i've expanded my services please
come take a look expanded huh
that isn't even thank you i like this
guy
he's trustworthy so we could sell all
this [ __ ]
like crimson glass valuable
would you like one i don't really see a
reason to hang on to it
crystal torso i assume these are made to
sell
right yeah yeah satisfied
i believe this is a fair price honestly
you have the
fairest prices of the land i've procured
some new items for you mr winters
excellent uh
greatly increases ammo capacity hmm okay
what about these
we don't need sniper mines
learn how to make mines using crafting
menu that's kind of fun
we could definitely afford it too we
have a lot of money oops
let me just look her around first what
we got uh
we upgraded our shotgun
we should definitely upgrade uh our
power yeah this simple modification can
be done in just a moment
excellent uh rate of fire
ammo capacity
[Music]
oh it's very very minimal
like 0.2 seconds quicker as soon
we can uh that seems sorry his hands are
more dexterous than one might think
i don't know if rate of fire is really
what i need
i don't need reload speedify securing
goods is more important than anything
anything my friend mm-hmm
let's try the mine thing yeah yes i can
see why you'd be interested in that
why are these free i'm so confused
oh
i saw you eyeing that one
why are these free
uh-huh
oh excellent okay
i see anything else thank you for your
patronage
let's go with that
nice very nice
oh we put the key of course all right so
we got the mask of sorrow
can we examine it knew we i knew it went
there
honestly i knew we went there
well i suppose we need three more hey
flower sword ball a ball made of metal
decorated with flowers and sword i
clearly doesn't
go in these ladies i apologize
okay
let's yeah let's try and find the sniper
where have we not been
mm-hmm or angel's bus got it and i've
been to the library
unless it's on another floor so
shall we make our way there all of joy
oh no
uh i have an appointment i i can't
i can't i can't miss it i just can't
miss it
and i i really i gotta go all right
i gotta go you coming with me just come
oh no i did i walk into a dead end i
meant to walk somewhere else
oh this is bad
sorry i i walked in the wrong room
no i feel i need to go this way
honestly mother mother
hold on oh hall of pleasure let's go
there
i this is awkward
okay excellent
hey mask of pleasure
we did it
silver ring we did it
oh we can make a mine how do i equip
it oh let's say
is there something else no
all right
yes
okay looks sketchy boot you made a bang
okay okay
soon we can't go there okay
i was worried my sisters had gotten here
first
well i've got bumps hey ain't no
seriously i got that
oh she locked me in
all right we're gonna have to kill now
how do i fight her i gotta hold it
i can't shoot her
i need to
powerful attack oh the bombs it's so
scary
ruined the hunt
it bastard no i missed my shotgun please
let me redo it
die [ __ ] mom's mine
stop it hurts it really hurts you're
done
no you're done [ __ ] no it's a lie
yeah i know i upgraded
my uh
[ __ ] crazy witch
that's mine now thank you that will sell
yes very good
cool that's two
and now we jump and go home
and we'll drink at the romanian pub
oh of course the skull i need an eye
yeah looking sharp it's weird like you
don't feel like this is supposed to do
anything but the game makes you do it
okay yes
no we're done here the face is glowing
with satisfaction
that's what i was about to say
wait wait wait what do i have to put it
back no
that's dumb but this was locked before
and we can't go here oh maybe i put the
okay i got it i
got it so smart
thank you
i got it of course
but i need but i need that
i like what
hurry hurry hurry hurry uh
i thought i could use a skull for sure
hmm
what am i missing okay i'll have to keep
looking around
yes i found it
okay
what if i
don't activate anything in here i dot it
all right i can examine items that's
right
ah
of course it's on a it's on a thingy
of course
you have to remove the thingy with your
thing of course
that looks better honestly you're
welcome
so smart i know
incredible ah dude um
oh mommy mommy i'm here i'm here mommy
mom
mom mom mom
damn it
hey mama i'm right here man
amen why
i will be the only child
[Music]
one of these days i'll be the only child
we need to go downstairs then back to
the hall of
four and put the thingy on the thing
mommy mommy i got love in my time
way long oh no this is bad
not good oh [ __ ] we're are we locked in
with mommy
that's all right i can hide she'll never
find me here
as long as she doesn't turn left here we
should be okay
[ __ ] uh uh she doesn't know where we are
she has no idea
[Music]
this is fine i'm just going to throw a
bomb here
you dumb [ __ ]
you're so dumb she fell for the oldest
bomb day you
[Applause]
close the doors close the doors close
the doors i know this is probably not
the time to do this
but i gotta put mask i gotta put mask
pleasure
i gotta put mass completion there's god
she's sleeping in here hello
i'll shop with you later save
[Music]
sorry did i wake you mate welcome
i have a crystal torso
would you like it i also found this
silver ring
last time we needed the ring but i doubt
they would make you sell stuff
i'm buying this because of our
relationship you know
i love our relationship and you know
that
where is the sniper rifle
do you increase the pyro this bad boy
yeah let's do it one moment please
securing goods is more please come again
well i thank you kind sir you've been
nothing but outstanding and trustworthy
see there you are actually i was going
back in
she here fit through that door she's too
fat am i right
[Music]
yeah he knows what i'm talking about
you can't combine treasure oh okay
i didn't know that well i'll keep an eye
out for that
i'm hungry drinking a snack
not really in the mood for snack but i'm
hungry i got some old g
fuel
hey can i have that ring back oh yes
that's only fair right
okay thank you for your patronage
i just feel like i was wrong mommy
mommy yes
alright two more
where should we go
labyrinth hustle oh let's check that out
my bad
labyrinth oh here it is yes
uh oh
cool whoa that's fun
okay all right we killed it here
all right all right gotta be careful
here
there we go nailed it
[Music]
there's three different holes we don't
want to hit the hole so we're gonna go
here
ah excellent
yes okay so should i sell that or
combine it
as you wish
ooh 8k baby
very valuable
where did you get your hands on such a
thing it was bro it was literally right
next to you
uh what is this
increase the number of items slides
available probably have to get that at
some point
what sound is he making and this is for
the shotgun
i don't think we need that learn how to
make shotgun ammo using crafting
that seems useful
get five shots for a thousand or we can
make for three thousand
i think i'll hang on to some money for
now actually
have a wonderful adventure why thank you
times uh
okay now uh
we haven't checked out the library yet
so i assume that's where we need to go
we need to go upstairs and left
and that wasn't that door locked though
doesn't that red mean locked
we don't really have anything to enter
yet oh that's a door we haven't explored
so where's that us up the stairs to the
right
you try that mommy i'm busy
very busy very busy boy i'm a busy boy
boy busy boy busy bye busy boy
[ __ ] she'll never find me don't worry
she can't find me
i'm hidden as a chameleon over here
we've definitely been here hold up so
it's just in here
you haven't been here oh thanks boots
thank you
oh [ __ ] is she coming in here boot did
you sell me out
you did not just sold me out mom
i'm just looting all right so we finally
you can't fit here that's hey mom
bye mom
oh loot
all right where are we going there's an
elevator we need to get the electricity
going that door is
locked we haven't been there how do we
even get there
we're kind of locked in here okay we can
make it right
yeah yeah let's go out there right
yeah yeah yeah okay
bye mom
yes yeah
uh-huh where what is it
okay in the corner
mm-hmm we're in the right place
we've definitely been here
she constantly chases you now hell yeah
i like that not gonna lie all right so
just around the corner here it should be
something
oh mommy's bathroom oh
oh we found the lipstick remember
she was looking for it's very expensive
oh mommy will be so pleased
mommy i found your lipstick
is this where they tell you about the
lipstick
we needed to return it where was it i
don't remember
do you guys remember
anyone remember where we're supposed to
put it in the bedroom maybe
maybe she'll stop killing us now
i like that you can jump over but you
can't
big mama bath water
where can you buy it
she's chasing me um [ __ ] i don't
let's go down here
no one remembers i think you can just
sally it's just very expensive oh gotcha
huh kind of lost to where to go then
i mean it must be here but the door is
locked iron insignia we have that now
so this is definitely we're going okay
gotcha so we need to go
to the opera hall and then upstairs
okay cool
and the opera hall is over here
hey mom even ah i get it i get it i get
it bro
i get it mom's getting mad
oh it was right nice
we're cool we're cool have we been in
the library no this is brand new
territory so you finally came to see me
everyone falls for me in time
no place to run well there's light right
here
dumb [ __ ] so mean
why are you doing this uh mommy's mine
am i damaging her i can't really why
would you do this
i don't know
am i damaged yeah we are
bro i'm just going to camp here and you
know it it's so cold
she fell for it again don't you love me
oh i do
no no no don't come here i know
it's not fair
just come here
all right i'm gonna to finish it off oh
god
damn
a dream i don't want to stop
bye bye
i'm sick of bugs nice
okay we got the crystal torso
we have a mine i forgot about that
raise the blaze
we got a big bubba we gotta get that big
big
was that all of them
there's three right have to do it i have
to do
double sided book shelves hello
fancy oh that's a nice pillow
ah here we go
always worth checking everywhere
we came from there there's no door here
so we gotta go here
hey what's up
how are you
oh that looks expensive
that's a chimney thingy
ah yes thank you
just one more baby just one more
okay let's check the small door so this
is just a short cut out
okay let's check out the actual yeah
oh cool damn
it doesn't do her justice she's larger
in real life
honestly it's right to god
what are we reading
folk povesti
love it my favorite series
it has to be done
hey that's sick how you doing man
not sure what we're supposed to
do here
that's like a puzzle room
ah here we go let the five bells of this
chamber ring out
i say oh there's one
oh cool i saw one up here
that's two there's one dangling wasn't
it yeah
oh
oh i got it okay i don't know how didn't
look like we hit it at all
s3 to whom the bellators
uh-huh it must be very hidden then or in
plain sight who [ __ ] house
uh
chandelier maybe ah there it is
now the last one uh it is in the
chandler
nice
now mommy will come
yeah boy
ah fresh air
i prefer the gunk of mommy but you know
kind of cool they're using the yellow as
a hint
to where you need to go they use that in
the beginning cut scene if you remember
as well
oh yeah okay
that's a long-ass ladder what the [ __ ]
what up pots
shame if something happened to you
oh another one after wasting ammo on you
fine so be it
oh box
when they leave them out in the open
like this i'm always like there has to
be like someone lurking
and look at that look at that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
play too much dark souls they always do
it
hey i know you i know you're fake
sleeping bro this is really awkward
yeah look at you all right get up
thank you for being useless fake sleep
on a better spot next time
[ __ ] hey lockpick
treasure
it was a dungeon and treasure and that's
all i saw
dragons
i heard there was something called the
dagger of death's flowers somewhere in
this castle
it's apparently an antique from the
middle ages that's coated in a
cocoa coconut of potions
poisons from across the continent it's
said to have been crafted to kill demons
and monsters
it sounds fascinating but no one knows
where it is well we just found a map
we can make a no we can't we need medals
should definitely make another med
sorry how do i i need to examine my map
we go uh okay
so kitchen
treasure there's a hair loom worth a
fortune in that noble mass casket but
there's a damn
trick to it nothing about lighting the
way
okay let's try finding this spot first
apparently it's concussion
concoction
concoction that's how you say it
we just need to find the dungeon and
then the kitchen we're in the attic all
right
is that what i think it is right on a
chair and playing my baby we can snipe
them now
[ __ ]
can we reorganize
oh it's huge maybe i'll upgrade the
inventory slide and we'll come back for
it
all right we can always come back for it
where the [ __ ] am i though
hey boo you made it
oh i wish i had a sniper here
oh you know what i'm gonna get i'm
getting this [ __ ] sniper
okay so if i drop them are they gone
forever or
it sucks
well honestly i could just discard them
something
why did i have to craft that [ __ ]
bomb maybe how do i rearrange
move oh okay here we go
okay we can can we fit that one two
three four five six now we can
it fits
got a [ __ ] inventory puzzle on our
hands
yeah that made all the difference
oops
can i rotate them no
we're so close to greatness
i think one hand bomb over a sniper
rifle is kind of a done deal isn't it
these which cannot be described in this
card area return them to your england
what
you can rotate oh
oh knee
thanks guys there we go
no i want it
like a glove
okay cool nice
is that it it's sniper time
okay shooting demon time
all right they're a little further away
and faster than i thought but
uh that's fine
uh which one do i shoot that one maybe
is that a bust or a zombie demon
what is that
that's definitely one of them all right
here we go
hold still now
okay perfect
psy coming from a mile away
this sniper sucks it barely zooms
how much ammo do i have i don't know
should i get closer
[Applause]
oh they drop a lot of money
okay definitely want to snipe them then
see if we can get a little closer
not yet mommy
hey hey hey hey hey i'm gonna snipe you
i'm gonna snipe you
i'm gonna sign you
i'm gonna i was gonna i was kind of
sniping
okay they're definitely worth killing
see that sniper i did on that guy
snap the [ __ ] out of him
[Music]
oh rich
uh-huh
quick stop quick uh wait hold up
hey hold up hold up bro hold up
hold up hold up i'm gonna snipe him
i'm sniping him i'm gonna snipe him
no not outside i don't get your money
now
idiot
all right for real sniper
because i was standing still
oh what what are you gonna do where are
you gonna do
what are you getting there huh where are
you going what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do where are you
going where you gonna be all right
where are you gonna do huh back up
are you dead confirmed dude they're so
rich
okay that one's flying in a circle but i
don't want to miss out on the items i
have to kill him over here
oh here we go
bye
no i was just about to shoot you
i have another scope since when
are you drunk
let's wait for them to land
idiots he's coming for me isn't he
that's fine
oh uh can you can you land like a little
closer to me and then
i'll shoot you no
there we go
closer don't fly out don't fly out i
need your money
don't come on the balcony
shot him in his foot deadly as always
just die chill like bro chill chill
nice
i like the game so far yeah it's
creepy but still kind of fun
with the action and shooting so
i like it it's nice
okay uh i don't think we got all of them
to be honest
[Music]
did we i don't see any of them
yes we can crack more now definitely
buying the inventory
as soon as we can get it uh
i'm sure we can get up there next and
we'll get
[Music]
so cool
i have a scope i'm so confused
well we're done with the cycling thing
for now very good there's my money
should be more
there should be a thousand buckaroonies
not yet where's my money
where's my [ __ ] money
maybe that was it
there was a scope in the elevator
and you can buy a scope from the big guy
well why are you telling me i have it
now then
i'll just reach out if i'm stuck if you
guys
stop
hey the last one nice
don't mind if i do okay i should be able
to get out with these
yes
very good
i think we got it all
could have used a ladder but you know
all right that's another way to do it
first elevator
i'm just gonna go
nice
the tiles very nice pile
ah here we are boots we're back
i think we're due for a
a shopping visit
is it through here yeah straight down
stupid mad thing you won't live long
even if you run okay
she is angry i understand
i've expanded my services please
excellent
take a look oh
if you hold back and circle you turn
quickly i didn't know that
seeking something in particular yes
i am i'm in need of your
storage experience so you notice that
uh we got crystal torso lady lipstick
people said just to sell it
so i'm gonna do that and dissatisfied
i believe this is a fair price
it sure was uh we can make shotgun ammo
we can make sniper rifle ammo
[Music]
or we could just buy each other we have
quite a bit of money what are you buying
just something an old friend of mine
used to say
there it is
sure [ __ ] it delighted too
sure and let's make it so we can craft
chocolate ammo
nice till next we meet indeed
oh i should actually
just gonna wait for mommy to go away
she's in a bad mood today
there are more
oh yes
why would i sell oh why would i sell
these
you guys drunk see every time i listen
to you guy
have a wonderful adventure mommy
mommy
we're fine
[Music]
we're fine uh
which one do you guys think this is mask
of joy yes mask
of rage oh no
mask of open this [ __ ] door
i've been lied to hey mom
now you're finished ethan winters but i
honestly i didn't even
are we mommy why you hurt me help me fat
buying
help me she's crazy
he's absolutely insane
i have to lit something up as well
what did i miss
oh wait what get out of here
whoa
we're in the church okay
where do we any zombies laying around
fake sleeping zombies anyway
nope all right
oh the poison dagger
thank you oh mommy please can i ruin
everything kill me mommy oh yes
oh sorry mom
oh
i'm so sorry oh
she's gonna transform oh that's not sexy
flesh
what do you think i'm still into it
i still like it she's still mommy
looks like you're outside
okay maybe we should have afraid
oh i am lucky
mommy chill
i'm trying to shoot her right
there
honestly this is all a big
misunderstanding
if you just go back to the other form i
think
i think we'll find it more pleasant for
all of us
all right i have a man hold up mom
i've been waiting to use this
uh mom don't use it now
their mind did nothing dude
oh fly fly yes
quick just give up
whoops
sorry mom we're cool right we're so cool
right
now
uh i'm i'm behind you
that's not what i said damn it
um
quick stuff space plane
that's not supposed to run up
oh more nice to go
don't be shy show me your
terror this is cool i like this fight
yeah okay maybe now
[ __ ]
we'll die together mom
damn it i didn't want to do it
[Applause]
you know i i could have listened to more
of that
you're the one who's cursed
that sucked that was awesome
we did it let's go
first boss completed sorry mommy
it had to be done is there a point of
playing keep playing here or should i
just quit
because she's dead she was the whole
reason hi
okay we'll keep going
exactly out of this place yeah
we should probably leave after this
rose all right
we're looking all right we got
bros indeed
we can make more stuff now
[Music]
i finished that island that was
requested please deliver to the house
with a red chimney
go through the caves to the ruins then
go into the village
okay red chimney
caves ruins got it no problem
we're back in the let me just make sure
i checked everything out
ah yes [ __ ]
i cannot it's either super hot or super
cold in here
there we go nothing
nice
uh oh toilet gotta check it
some gunpowder
get that explosive dire all right
what was this a glass container with a
flower sword crest
it's too dirty see inside
i need some yeah i definitely need some
other items
i don't know what did we use last time
what am i missing
i don't know
um
hmm so many tools here
what oh close
hmm
tool some sort of lever
in the boat perhaps about down here
ah
nope
can we shoot that down no i don't think
so
how do i get stuck on the obvious [ __ ]
mom do you have like a screwdriver or
something
oh my god are you serious i can just
shoot the lock of course
there goes nothing big brain
huge so large six pack eight pack brain
oh little fishies hello
gonna get some disease for sure but
that's alright
to deliver us into faith's hands
as the midnight moon rises on black
wings
so we make the sacrifice yes
life which one is this one i want to see
the little one that was so cool
is it a shotgun moment great ones hear
our voice together as one in reverence
sorry to interrupt call on me as the
middle oh it's hard
rises on black wings we await the light
at the end
in life and in death glory to mother
miranda
hey remember me i almost died up at that
castle
tell me what is going on around here
how can a man be almost dead
oh that's a question for the wise
you know what i mean and i still haven't
found rose
where did mother miranda take her
[Laughter]
you are too late or maybe
almost too late nice the child will be
sacrificing we walk right into that one
what kind of sick medieval [ __ ] is this
she's just a baby
the crests of the four bloodlines may
open the path you seek will you please
stop talking
in riddles all right there was some
[ __ ] my daughter
a giant hammer guy it's only original if
you don't know the
answer
wait a second that looks familiar
hey hey wait oh [ __ ] locked me in
are you serious
oh she left me again that's nice over
here
almost too late
it's kind of cozy like what you did with
the place
somebody use the little key here
yes
nailed it i'm the best
the [ __ ] greatest
so they said walk through the dungeons
right this is it
hold the lever okay i love how his hands
are still working i
i need that compilation of someone
with ethan's hands getting [ __ ] up is
this
this looks so cool
very cool
uh-huh so oh it's umbrella corp isn't it
no way
whoa some industrial
chimneys
so
i like this cool area
oh box remember the rule
all right sniping time i guess
oh where are though
it's not like they're down here oh
whoa oh there's another one
ah [ __ ]
i'll snipe them all if i have to i'm
gonna come through here
i think he already made it through
god i hate no
[ __ ]
i don't like them fast i like them slow
and wonky
oh there we go
come back come back please
say awkward when they're hunched over
there we go
hey where's your head out now
[ __ ] nice
anyone else
a quick scope all of you oh poor
romanians
i'm ready for you
oh my is here
there's a drawbridge we should probably
lower it
nice
this is suss oh
little goatee bye
it's very classical in its game gameplay
maybe winky will work no we need a
[ __ ] lever again
but i like that in a way
what we got here nice i guess
that boss battle was really cool though
but other than that there's not much
that feels like oh this is next-gen
stuff like they're doing different [ __ ]
oh that was terrible oh god oh god
all right we're gonna have to redo this
one
god they moved so much
i hate thee
could have done a sneaky on him see they
did it again
all right moving on
we walked in here didn't we
nope
kind of key goes in there probably none
of the ones we have
worth a shot
okay let's remember that that needed a
key
in the lone road all you walker
no so pretty i love the
[Music]
level design
nice doesn't look evil at all
winky goes there what there you are
i had a feeling you would pop up here
uh-huh
it was all worthless is that so
i assume you've picked up something of
value
not sure if it's a value but oh
why you have your daughter right in your
own hands
yo what are you saying i can drink her
take a closer look look closely
nice
we gotta reassemble her like we
reassemble our hand
i just dropped flask seems to contain
her head
no
roses don't say another word
this this is impossible this just can't
be
your daughter's essence is still intact
her powers are truly
unique
who could even do this she can be saved
you know
saved from this are you insane
there's a house with a red chimney on
the western side of me yeah yeah we know
go and seek out the man who lives there
then we can continue our conversation
i've done this holding out and get to
the damn point
you don't have to trust my words
but do you have any better options
what if i tickle your feet will that
change your mind choice
the customer is always right
after all
he'll pay you if i find out this is a
lie
ah [ __ ] joker
oh good i was just thinking of ways to
pass the tie
i'm so angry at you but also do take a
look at my new stock
let's oh we got a lot for her
i'll sell that [ __ ] see oh lady
dimitrisk
beautiful even in death that waistline
yes
i see you're a man of culture as well we
can upgrade this even more now let's do
power
this to me
i think it really this simple
modification can be done in just a
moment
see what else he's selling first thirty
thousand for more
uh there's a scope
and um reduces weapon sway
oh [ __ ] that's cool so you can really
upgrade the sniper
we can make pipe bombs we can make
sniper ammo
i almost feel like we should buy one of
these
food is life food please come again
indeed yo you're selling lattice
same
okay i assume this is like a hub area
and we have to go into all these three
doors
which one first he did say house of in
the
west did he say wes
let's go over there
uh-huh he said this way
yes
um oh yeah we're stuck again
i can't get past this there's just no
way i can
possibly make it best
all right that's gonna be it's gonna be
bad guys here i know
we'll just keep our eyes open
red chimney hmm
that's not red that's kind of red
that's actually red
where's the entrance
god damn ag getting no luck here
but hmm
this [ __ ] again
we can go through here hold up let's
look at the map
can't go that's the house we need to go
to
where is it
that's the house but it looks like we
can totally just enter here
nope that road is definitely blocked
unless you can fall no
it's weird how it is in show that is
blocked on the map um
we can go
okay
let's watch out for our evil zombies and
stuff while we're at it
ah all right guess we have to go through
where there's clearly a zombie
hello hello
any romanians
they love that song they can't get
enough of it
i need to get on their good side you
know
chill
oh thank you
okay oh toilet gotta check it
always check the toilets nice
only one pot brand in this village huh
come on romania
you disappoint me
definitely through here
check that out in a sec just
yep
you [ __ ] what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do
[ __ ] gonna knife the rest i'm gonna
knife the rest
gotta knock the rest [ __ ] save that
ammo on your [ __ ]
yeah cool weapon though
ah my toilet no
romanian this is my toy you know
i'll never forgive their radius okay so
where are we now we
need to go to the road and then make a
right okay
oh another nice tractor
that's like a [ __ ] trap let's clear
out first
nothing but fabs i feel like we've been
here
are you doing mate
uh what is that i definitely don't have
anything
can we move you i think he's sleeping on
it let's follow where this cable goes
okay so we got to get that moving by
attaching this to a cable
which is probably over here
although i hear you
check here first
we got blood
that looks very particular isn't it
hey look at that someone hit some ammo
in there
good places any
there's under the sink there was a lever
under the sinker i thought i checked it
no it says close you fools
i i even knew that what's wrong with you
guys
why do you get so stuck in chat
everyone's spamming under the sink
you blind fools
is that a sink did we find the sink guys
look out the window
oh oh oh which window this one
okay so the passcode is out the window
okay
uh huh okay oh cool
zero eight zero four excuse me
did you set me up for this hello that's
very rude
back up back up back the [ __ ] up
is this covering it
there's seven they're already
where it's the last one
oh there we go
i put the wrong
was it sarah seven oh god
okay a better gun
but i just maxed out my other one
jack handle under the sink thanks guys
thanks for the help chad
hold that
small semi-automatic fully automatic oh
okay
almost missed you
it's sniper attack
i hear them i ain't seen them oh there
you go
oh [ __ ]
let's try this new gun that i'm [ __ ]
up with
if you shoot them right before they
attack they back up
nice
you drop any loot oh sad
oh rich boy
mmm i'm smelling lunch and it smells
delicious
this is not the jack handler is it
what ow out of that
okay we can go underneath now
who's playing tricks on me
oh sure wish i had a sniper
all right we can sniper that gun
not so fast not so fast
i said i need to learn how to [ __ ]
block i keep hitting the medical button
this button
okay
we're going to house a red chimney which
is this one
seriously
another way where am i why am i going
this way
no wait yeah this way well let's
actually this looks like a dead end we
should check it out
might be stopped
nope fine
we have an ex oh we've been here well
horsey
he's fine okay load out in the open
always be wary
yes i wish we went here first
i could have sniped them
hello hello
someone's eating too many eggs
and cocaine it's a good combo underrated
honestly
we can lockpick it
yes nice
more sniper time
i'm not gonna snipe in here though
oh that a
pig should i kill it it's probably a
nice pig
right are you a good pig or a bad pig
i will leave the pig b for now he has
not done anything to me
but i will keep it's a bad pig
that was a good pig have a good life pig
you just want to see your again that's
fine
yes we have that
then we use the light jack-o-lantern
thing
what what was that i gotta check this
out
you all right hey you know
that's not fresh you gotta eat fresh i
got eggs and bacon and they all not
baking sorry
we're gonna be best friends
can we ride the ping
we can push the pig there you go
trust me you don't want to eat that
trust me bro
let's push into the eggs all right this
way
you're gonna eat good tonight boy
you gotta get eggs tonight a real feast
trust me much higher in protein
it's not vegetarian but it's veggie
i think you'll like it almost there pee
pee poop yes
a lot of people don't know about this
easter egg
in the game where if you push him
to the eggs you unlock the good ending
it's a happy ending for the pig at least
okay
he's still eating that's fine he doesn't
know any better
he's a pig after all
there you go there you go that's
that tastes better this yeah you got
eggs now you're walking
better than a dead horse that's been out
there forever
oh look he's so happy now we did it
oh [ __ ]
okay sorry it's just i wanted him to
have an
nice final meal you know
is it lunch time okay nice
lunch time very hungry
[Music]
cool game is getting better and better i
really like it
hope you are as well i'll see you in the
next part guys thanks for watching
a professed very good
[Music]
you